importing that and all of the useful
stuff is in the sub module called tensor
so we usually import that as T so the
key difference between piano and
something like numpy is that it supports
symbolic variables so we can create one
of these through the tensor module will
create a scalar symbolic variable if you
look at that it's something called a
tensor type it says the dimensionality
and the data type but it doesn't have
about you it's just a variable so once
we have a variable we can write a
mathematical expression using that so
here we'll define Y is 3 x squared plus
1 and if we look at the resulting object
that we get it's also a tensor variable
so it's not quite the same as X but it's
basically is very similar we can do a
lot of the same things with it and if we
want to take a look at this what's
called a symbolic expression if we print
it we get something that's not super
informative but it's telling us this is
what's you know it calls an op or it's
an operation so basically this is the
last operation in calculating that
expression that we defined so if you
want to dig a little deeper Danah has a
function called P print which can show
us the full computational graph of that
expression and now we can see some
similarities to what we typed before and
a slightly nicer way of looking at it is
something called debug print which just
formats this a little bit differently
and it shows the sequence of ops that
are getting making out this expression
down here we can see this is our
original X our tensor tape and the final
way if you want to look at anise or more
graphical a I'm using PI dot and graph
is I personally find this a lot easier
to understand or to read we can see we
had this was our original variable X
we're taking a constant value 2
through this power operation and then we
combine it with the times three adding
one and we finally get output now if we
want to actually get an answer out of
this we have to evaluate the expression
and the way to do that is this eval
method on the expression variable so we
have to supply a dictionary telling Thea
what values to put into our input
variable in which case in this case it's
just X we're going to supply the value
to and we get out a numerical answer so
this is good for you know like a quick
one-off evaluation but we can also
compile a function where now we're going
to call this piano function called
function we're going to tell it the
inputs we're going to give it as X and
the output we want is the our expression
Y and that's gonna return the callable
function f so now we can just call that
function with our into it and we get out
the answer question do i what
so in this when you're compiling the
function you have to give it X because
what thanos gonna do is it's gonna see I
want to calculate Y so it's gonna try
and figure out what has to do to
calculate Y if I don't give it X it's
gonna give me an error saying missing
input or something like that because it
doesn't know what to put into the
expression yeah
good question but once it's compiled I
can put in anything I want
oh so one peculiarity is it always
expects a list of inputs because you
often have multiple inputs going into an
expression so even if you have a single
one you have to put it into a list and
you can also you could have lists here
multiple outputs that you wanted to
compute as well if multiple expressions
to find the same input again so once you
compile a function we can take a look at
that in the same way we did before and
we can see that it's been transformed a
little bit from the graph that we saw
earlier and this is one of the nice
things about Theano is it can apply a
number of optimizations when it's doing
this compilation and also in this case
another really nice thing is a lot of
the time it can transparently compile
your your operations to run out GPU so
that's why we see here this GPU from
host and host from GPU it's actually
transferring the data to the GPU doing
this tiny operation and sending it back
which is not something necessarily want
for this but for many times that can be
or give you a real speed-up
yes so addition the scalars you have
other things tensors matrices and three
and four dimensional tensors are sorry
vectors matrices if you need something
bigger than that you can define your own
tensor type but usually this would give
you all the variables you would need and
you can do a lot of the normal stuff you
would do in numpy with these expressions
you can do indexing and you can even do
you know fancy indexing although this
will often this use a knob called
advanced sub tensor which can often be
somewhat inefficient so you want to be
careful how fancy you get you can also
do a lot of numerical calculations
functions either through variable
methods or through the you know tensor
module but you shouldn't try and use
just arbitrary numpy functions on thea
variables a lot of the time it will work
because Nano is pretty smart about
converting things into back and forth
between numpy but sometimes you'll get
something that looks like we're
expecting something that's just not what
you expected at all so to be safe you
should always use the Theano functions
so another really nice thing about the
endo because it has what's called
automatic differentiation so pretty much
all of the ops that uses know how to
calculate their gradient and so if you
want to get the derivative of something
of the gradient with respect to
something it can basically go backwards
from that output and calculate anyway
that's pretty efficient and you
basically you don't have to do any other
work you can just define your expression
and then call this T that grad so we're
gonna take the gradient of log of X with
respect to X and that gives us another
expression for the gradient if we we can
just evaluate that expression
so that is really handy when you're
working with neural networks because a
lot of the time you're trying to do
gradient descent so the first thing you
need is a gradient you feel loss
function what's that I think I'm not
really clear on the distinction like I
think it's not really symbolic in the
sense of like mathematic it would give
you a symbolic derivative but it does
work on these symbolic expressions so
it's not like in numerical
differentiation so another really
important part of Theano is what's
called shared variables so that's
combining one of these symbolic
variables with some storage so we can
create a shared variable from a numpy
array and something that I should
mention that's pretty important is if
you're ever working with the GPU which a
lot of times you want to be they
typically only support float32
data and so you have to be careful that
anytime you're putting something into a
female variable you cast it to float32
otherwise either you'll get a Theano
error or it will sort of it won't be
able to move that computation of the GPU
and so your program might run a lot
slower than it would otherwise so that's
why Theano can be configured to work
with either 32 or float 64 by default
and that's stored in this variable do
you know that config that float X so
here I'm creating a shared variable and
so we see that if I look at what I get
it's not the same thing as the I had
before but it's still and it's a sort of
thing called a CUDA in the array so that
tells me that it's on the GPU it tells
me a datatype
and it tells me what kind of tensor is
and once we have this then we can get
and set the value that's stored in there
so we can
I mean used to get value you can see
that it has the shape that we put in
there and when you have a bunch of zeros
and we could also put some other value
into there with the set value and we can
use this the same way we used normal
symbolic variable we can write an
expression we get an expression back but
the key difference is when we evaluate
this expression we don't need to give an
input anymore it's gonna use the value
that was stored in that shared variable
so we can just take that expression
directly call eval on it with no
parameters and we get out the right
answer and if we want to compile a
function now we don't need to pass any
inputs but we still give an empty list
and we can just get function back and
call it we get the answer question well
let me see if the next slide explains
that so the use for this is that there's
something called updates so now you
might want to have a function that
calculates something and you can then
take the sum of the output of that
function and map it back into one of
your shared variables and then when you
call the function you know it's gonna
automatically update that shared
variable and so here's just a little
example I create a shared variable the
value 0 I create an expression so we're
gonna increment count by 1 and then we
define our updates which is just mapping
count to this new count expression now
we compile a function it doesn't take
any inputs it calculates count so it's
gonna return the current value of count
and it's going to apply these updates
that we just undid so we call that get 0
next time we call it and get one call
again 2 and so this becomes useful when
you have something like gradient descent
you define a function that's going to
calculate it's going to take your
gradients calculate an update step and
then you can
apply that on a glee to your weight
matrices or what not so yeah so that's
basically that's the very basics of
piano and those are the things that you
would find yourself using most often are
there any questions yes yeah so that's
the other thing so you saw it was like a
CUDA nd array so that means it's being
is lives on the GPU if I'm doing a
computation on the GPU it can store the
the update there without having to come
back to the host and then back to the
GPU so yeah I would speed things up a
lot yeah I mean I think I mean was
created by a neural network lab people
use it for other machine learning things
I'm sure someone's using it for
differential equations I don't know of
any examples off top of my head though
yeah so it's Nvidia only people are
working on
OpenCL but it's not there yet so if you
want to try this I've made a another
notebook with a few exercises and try
them out later if you want and yeah let
me know if you have any questions you
want me to go through any of these
basically just you know calculate a
simple function cackling something using
updates and then calculating something a
little more complicated you can
implement the game of life
I think I'm gonna move on to lasagna
SOLAS Anya is a lightweight library
meant to make it easier to build and
train your own networks using Fiona and
so it's basically two things
it's a bookkeeping device and the
collection of helper functions and so I
mean by bookkeeping device is when
you're creating a neural network you
typically have layers of neurons and you
want to take the output from one layer
put it into another layer and so forth
and when you're doing that you have to
create a bunch of weight matrices and to
do that you need to know you know the
size of your output how it changes as
you propagate through the network and
that can be a little tricky if you know
when you have symbolic tensors that
don't have a shape until you evaluate
them so basically what lasagna does is
it does all the sort of all the work of
calculating higher shape changes and
automatically creating weights and
biases of the right shape for you and it
also has does a few things to make the
API a little cleaner and more consistent
and along with that it implements a
number of useful things like variants of
gradient descent or different
initialization schemes for your weights
different objective functions and
basically it's it's intended to be as
simple and transparent as it can be and
to not really hide Theano but to just
give you things that work with the
amount of expressions let you use the I
know when you need to but just make a
little easier to define these kind of
structures so the main part of lasagna
are layer classes so these are meant to
be an abstraction of a layer of neurons
and network but there's also layers that
do other things like just shaping your
output in different ways taking slices
or reshaping
and the main things that they do are
they know what layer they're getting
their input from and they as I said they
propagate the shape of your data through
the network and they also create and
manage the parameters of each layer
which is typically a weight in a matrix
and the BIOS vector so there's some
other important modules in it which has
these different ways of initializing the
weights objectives gives you different
loss functions and evaluation metrics
regularization gives you functions to
calculate different penalties on your
parameters and updates is another big
one which has a bunch of different
methods for grading at the Sun and
unfortunately this is too big this is
just a quick overview of the typical way
you would use lasagna so you would
define your layer sequence you would
start with an input layer where you
would define the shape of the input
coming into the network and then you
would add some other layers it could be
you know just fully connected dense
layers then you would call a lasagna
function giving it some input variable
and you would get an output expression
for the data once it's been propagated
through this network you then define the
loss function given that output and some
other symbolic input that's your target
labels you then pass that to one of
those functions from the updates module
so some optimizer and you also have to
give that all of the parameters and the
layers in your network which'll Sonia
can give you and that will give you a
set of updates which you would then use
to compile a function that would update
your parameters and then you can just
call that function in the training loop
and it will drain your network and
there's some good resources there's
fairly comprehensive documentation
there's also this repository it has a
lot of examples and the Google user
group is fairly active if you have
questions are there any questions about
any of that okay so I'm gonna
demonstrate that that will work flow I
showed you with a simple example on em
nest and that's kind of boring but we'll
get to some other things shortly so I
basically start out doing all our usual
imports and empathy I know lasagna
yeah that is a good question does anyone
know how to make the text bigger sorry
but okay is that better
okay that's not good okay
okay so we do our imports you want
usually see the random number generator
you can download the data set and a nice
Python format from this address we can
load it
split into training and test validation
so the data was originally 28 by 28
images but it's been flattened and to
just show me a four dimensional array
and we have 50,000 training examples and
just a good idea of what they look like
if you haven't seen them before we can
Paul if you're a few of them so we have
handwritten numbers and we're gonna be
trying to you know classify these into
what number they are so in order to
Train we're gonna want to define Network
and then we're gonna treat and we're
gonna feed our data through in small
batches so you do this for efficiency
particularly if you're on the GPU you
can process a number of examples in
parallel so we're just gonna define a
little function generator that's going
to return us small batches of images and
labels and we're gonna start with
basically the simplest possible network
so we're just gonna define an input
layer and we're going to tell it the
dimensionality of the input and here we
could put the batch size but if we put
none that's gonna make it more general
so we can later call this network with
any number of examples any bad as we
want and then we're going to have a
dense layer or fully connected layer
where we're connecting it to the input
layer we're gonna have ten units or
neurons and we're gonna have a soft max
non-linearity after the output so that's
going to give us a probability
distribution over these our ten classes
then we're gonna define symbolic
variables for our input which will be a
matrix B
we have a batch dimension and then our
one-hour vector input and our targets
are just going to be a vector so I
vector tells me that it's a vector of
integers okay so then we want to
calculate the output after propagating
through this network and we to do that
we use this helper function lasagna
layers get output and for this you want
to give it the output layer where you're
trying to calculate the output and it's
also going to need the input variable
and so this is gonna this is going to go
back through our network until it finds
the input layer and that's gonna apply
this input variable there it can be a
little confusing because you might not
expect you might think that this would
just give you the output of some
particular layer there's different
function get output for which could then
you can supply the input going to that
layer and would give you the output just
that one layer but by default you want
to propagate backwards until you could
get to the input and we can also so this
output like I said it's a probability
distribution you can also get a
predicted class by taking the the Arg
max it's over the final dimension
because we don't want to we still want
to leave the batch dimension intact so
now that we have an output we can define
a loss function so we're gonna use in
lasagna objectives this categorical
cross entropy loss and so we give it our
output expression and our symbolic
targets and so we're using categorical
cross entropy because our input targets
are integers so I'm like zero through
nine you could also have like a one hot
encoding
in which case you'd use a different
objective function and then so piano to
calculate the gradients we need to give
it a scalar loss function so we're just
gonna take the mean over this will be
over the batch it's over all the
dimensions that day so to me that's
dimension and we can also compute the
accuracy just to get another idea of how
well we're doing and for that so we're
using this T dot e quit comparing our
predicted class and the symbolic targets
and again we'll compute the mean over
the batch so the next step is to get all
the parameters in our network and we do
that using this other helper function
get all params again we're gonna pass an
output layer and it's gonna travel back
through the network finding all the
layers that are connected to it and by
default layers are tagged with whether
or not they're trainable so this is just
something you could change if you had
something that layering network you
didn't want to train for example you
could change the tags on it and then
this you can also add your own tags and
then give filters here to tell it which
parameters you want to get so if you
look at what we get we just have that
single layer with its weights and biases
it's the next step we calculate the
gradients it's just two that grad of the
loss with respect to those parameters
from there we can calculate updates
we're getting is basic vanilla
stochastic gradient descent we give it
the gradients the parameters and some
value for the learning rate and if you
look over get it's a update dictionary
so it's mapping our weight matrix to
some expression for the update and
similarly for the biases create a
training function so f train we have to
give it inputs images and targets and
we're gonna have it compute for us the
loss and the accuracy so we can see how
it's doing and it's also going to
automatically apply those updates we do
basically the same thing for validation
but here we don't want to do any updates
because this is our validation to it we
don't want to train with it and finally
once it's trained we can compute another
function that's just gonna give us the
predicted class if we wanted to we could
do the output here if we wanted a
distribution so let's pick a batch size
we're just gonna compute some number of
batches approximately equal one pass the
data I'll call that an epoch so this is
being a little looser but they'll be
fined for this create generators that
will give us data batches for training
and validation and just try that out so
you can see that it's working we can get
a batch of images and labels and we'll
just look at the first one it's an image
of a five we've got a five that's a
label so that's working so now to
actually do the training we just do an
outer loop for ten a pox and we're gonna
track how we're doing and loss and
accuracy so in each epoch we
for a number of mini batches we'll get a
batch of data call our training function
and we get out the loss in accuracy
values
well accumulate those and then average
and they'll do the same thing for
validation and finally it'll just print
out how we're doing and the other thing
that's useful to look at is the ratio of
validation loss of training losses so
tell us if or give us some idea of how
badly were overfitting seems to start
out yet pretty quickly a a percent
accuracy after tiny box we got up to
about 92% accuracy and it won't really
go up from here and so this is a pretty
bad accuracy but we have a very simple
Network and so basically I mean what we
have is equivalent to logistic
regression on the pixel values and then
one of the exercises ask you to use
scikit-learn to try a logistic
regression you'll see that you get
basically the same value we can then
take a look at where our train weights
look like so it's a shared valid
variable so we can use get value we
access so we have our layer we can
access the weights and get the value
there as an array and we see that we
have you know one weight for each pixel
in the input and then we have one of
these for each neuron in the layer and
we can view those as images and you can
sort of see it's learn something that
looks kind of like the digits 0 & 1
they're pretty easy to see the others
maybe not so much and so yeah you can
see that this is basically the same as
logistic regression another thing you
can try is adding another layer of
neurons
in between the infant put I'll just know
so yeah that's a pretty simple thing to
do you just define a hidden layer and
then you connect your output to that and
said so if you run this come up here but
you'll see you get up to I know
something like 97% accuracy you can try
playing with different numbers of
neurons different numbers of layers
anything that's also important is the
optimizer if you try different
algorithms you can see they'll converge
you know quicker they might also diverge
you ought to play with the learning rate
a lot of the time and the other thing
that's kind of interesting is you can
look at the weight values that you get
and you'll see that they can look very
different depending on what algorithm
using and that can be quite important
when you're working with more complex
networks because even though you might
get two very similar performance you're
actually a very different sort of part
of the parameter space and they can have
a big effect on your ultimate
performance
are there any questions about this I'm
not long actually
yeah sorry I should run this before but
okay you can see here it's going now
sticking about a second for epoch and
most of the time is actually probably
because it's running on the GPU
transferring data back and forth it's
not really doing anything complicated I
need to see this one got to God so here
we're maybe overfitting a little bit you
can see that the we have a ratio about
1.5 and our training accuracy is about
98% but validation is only 97 so in this
case you might want to add some sort of
regularization to that in layer yep
not really so that's gets back to I was
saying so it's they said you know
lasagna is not to do like every possible
thing but to make it really easy to do
things yourself and so you can see I had
to write my own training loop but
there's not really anything to it it's
just a Python loop so if you wanted to
do early stopping I could just you know
calculate this ratio train the vowel and
if have some condition to break out of
this loop so that's a great question in
this case I would because of the way I
did it but you could also give a shared
variable here instead of a constant
learning rate and then inside that tiger
loop I could update the value of that
shared variable
yeah so let's take a look
so it has a number of things has added
Delta a de grad and Adam so all of these
will adjust the learning rate per
program there yep
sir I'm not sure understand yeah so I
guess the next thing I'll talk about is
convolutional I'll Aires
I'm thinking other questions
honestly not really there are some good
you know tutorials in debugging but I
generally yeah the errors you get can be
very annoying it's hard to tell what's
going on but at this point for this sort
of feed-forward networks they're they're
pretty well debugged if you're using
lasagna and you're following the
documentation on what kind of inputs to
get you really shouldn't get any errors
when you start doing your own things it
gets a little more difficult
so I'm talking about so the alternative
so we had that dense layer so we were
connecting every pixel in the input to
each neuron either in that hidden layer
and so that's a lot of parameters and so
we over fit very quickly even with just
a single layer in there
the alternative is convolutional Network
where we define small kernels which are
convolve with the input and then those
give us an output image so this is a
simple example we're going through the
same thing we just did but now we're
gonna instead of a densely a fully
connected in layer where you use a
single convolutional layer so one thing
here now we can't use our our vector
input first we have to reshape it into
an image so that's just adding this
reshape layer we use minus 1 and for the
batch size another thing if you're not
familiar with convolutional networks the
typical convention for the data is you
have a batch dimension a channel
dimension which is like RGB and then
your 2 image dimensions so we want a 4
dimensional input so that's what we're
gonna get from our reshape layer here
and then we do a comp to do later just
we have a 2d input so we're gonna take
the input from this this reshaped layer
we're just gonna have three kernels and
we're gonna make them three by three and
we're also gonna use we're gonna pad the
input with one zero on each border just
so that we'd get an output the same size
yep
um yeah sorry I should have had some
slides on this so basically if you
imagine just like a like a one well we
have a one challenge but so we have some
input matrix and we're going to define
our kernel is just a three by three
matrix so at every position in the input
we multiply and sum over that 3x3 area
and that gives us one pixel on our
output and then we sweep that kernel
over the full image so we end up with an
output image ignoring edge effects of
the same size and then it's typical that
you have a multi-channel input so there
you have one your kernel is three
dimensional with one layer for each
Challenger and but and the convention is
to then sum over those channels so you
end up with a one channel output but you
have one channel for each of these
kernels in your layer and you typically
have many of them times up make sense
let's see so basically so you have this
larger input image and you have this 3x3
kernel so just like say we're at
starting at the top left corner you
would take that 3x3 region at the top
left corner you would do like a
element-wise multiplication with your
3x3 kernel and then would sum all those
values interesting a lot of hood so I'm
doing 3 filters just because well so the
number of filters here has no relation
to the input basically it's just each
filter is going to be a sort of feature
detector and I decided I wanted three of
them mainly because then I can plot the
output as an RGB image just a second and
then after this we have a dense layer
same as before
so we're basically we're barely
increasing the complexity versus our
logistic regression basically after this
convolution we now have a 3 by 28 by 28
data instead of 1 by 28 by 28 but we can
see when we run this we get up to you
know pretty high accuracy just with
three filters if you added more filters
more layers you could push this even
farther so but what I want to do is look
at the output after it's gone through
this convolutional layer so we can do
that just by using get output again but
here we're not using our output layer
we're using our our convolutional layer
and we get expression for the filtered
image and then we calculate function to
evaluate that so we're just going to
look at the first few training examples
we've run it through this function we
get out ten images and just reshape them
a little bit and we can plot these this
works sometimes this works sometimes it
doesn't
okay yeah so what I find interesting is
I'm looking to see the blue
very well but basically the different
filters have learned to be sensitive to
different parts of the input so here it
looks like blue is highlighting this
horizontal red is more vertical and
green is maybe Daniel Ayane and so this
could you some idea of how this can help
improve the accuracy and then the basic
idea the deep learning is then you have
many of these feature detectors and you
have many layers so you're hopefully
creating features that can be sort of
composed into into other features that
are more abstract but because you're you
don't have so many free parameters it
sort of should learn things that are
reusable and generalize well which
hopefully lets you um get good results
without so much overfitting are there
any questions about this
so each filter yeah that's correct it's
a good question so they start out random
so that's where the let's see
so when we define this comp 2d layer
it's going to give them some random
initialization actually so you can give
it a value for the weight matrix and the
default is this initialization scheme
you could also use one of the other
initializers or some value of your own
and then yeah they'll be trained through
the training loop that we defined if we
wanted to instead of good after it's
trained we could access those
and so this is you know the training
values and if we want do it apart these
and see what they looked like I could do
before do you a question let's see and
that's a good question I mean that's
another one of the advantages of the
convolution is that it should be
somewhat it's so one of the assumptions
I guess of it is that your input should
be somewhat translation invariant we
should expect that if the thing moves it
shouldn't change our output and one of
the ways of doing that is to define a
deeper network where you use pooling
operations to take the average of the
feature output over some small window
and so then if your input shifted within
that window you get the same output so
that's how you would incorporate
translation invariance
yes sir right so we had this would be
the first filter a second third so yeah
so 27 weights plus all the weights from
these so again there's still there's way
more than this weights connecting the
output dense layer yeah so if we did
so if we get all the primers we can see
that we have two sets of weights and
biases for the convolutional and the
output layer and yeah you can give your
weights more informative names if you
have a complicated network and you want
the hotel where these parameters came
from
what do you mean by different sort of
scheme Oh
so yeah that's another important point
so by default there is a rectified
linear a rectified linear non-linearity
after every complex
yeah
I don't I'm not sure
I'm not it's not sure I understand you
but I mean I think basically the
gradient gets back propagated through
each step and so it only receives
gradients that passed through the
rectified layer on my area so that does
cause problems if for instance you only
had a negative activation you would have
no you have no gradient because you're
out there would always be zero but that
usually doesn't that doesn't happen that
often in practice because you'll have a
large mini batch and so hopefully for
some example you'll get some positive
activation and yeah I think so yeah yeah
yeah it's not really an average it's um
yeah
I mean yeah if the if you can say that
there's a meaningful sequence and it has
you know local regularity then it should
be meaningful so time series should
probably work protein sequence I think
people have a part to that problem it's
not immediately clear to me that there
is a lot of local structure in it so
that's where the pooling comes in so you
hope that you know as you pull your
outputs you're getting a longer range
view
so here I'm gonna show a slightly more
interesting example so here I'm going to
take a large network that someone else
trained on this imagenet dataset which
is a data set of millions of natural
images with something like a thousand
categories and I'm gonna apply it to my
own classification problem and this is
often a really useful thing if you have
some image data set but it's fairly
small and you don't want to acquire you
know a million images of your own and
then spend weeks training a network you
can take the pre-trained network and
just tweak the weights a little bit and
use on your own data so just a silly
example I went on google image search
and I got a few hundred images of either
pancakes or waffles so let's say I miss
a little bit just to show you a few of
the images there in this image directory
there's some pancakes waffles so I mean
this isn't I mean it's pretty obvious
what it is but if you're just you know
someone gave you images like this how
would you go about doing it I mean it's
not a necessarily a trivial image
classification problem I mean they're
pretty similar colors they're both round
I guess these have some different
texture to them so the network arena
uses what's called a vgg 16 it's a 16
layer model it was either it was one of
the top scoring models a few years ago
in this image net image recognition
challenge and it's basically the same as
what we've it's not really using
anything new that we haven't seen yet
except for pool 2d layer which just does
this down sampling operation that was
talking about
pulling so pulling just you can define a
pooling Colonel usually two or three so
it's just gonna take out two by two
window in your input and either take the
maximum value or the average value
within that window and it's gonna apply
that across your image to give you
another image that's smaller by a factor
of two or three aware of your factor was
well so I mean by itself it's just a
layer that does that pulling operation
then you could add another convolutional
layer after that to do another set of
convolutions you typically wouldn't
proceed it because then you could just
down something your data before but yeah
what usually happens if you look at the
structure of this network we're feeding
in RGB image that's to 24 by 24 pixels
and there's two layers of convolution
followed by the layer of pooling and
then that repeats another two layers
convolution another layer of pooling
then three pool three pool so it's
that's a typical it's a fairly common
arrangement that seems to work pretty
well is either two or three convolution
layers followed by a pooling layer and
then just repeat that until your final
output image is a manageable size like
five by five or seven by seven something
like that after that then they apply a
couple of fully connected layers
followed by this final fully connected
layer is the output class fair so in the
original problem there were a thousand
classes so they had one unit per class
and then the softmax at the end of that
there's no non malaria pooling layer but
in each convolutional layer
yeah I mean you could add a
non-linearity there if you want to but
there won't really be a point because
basically if you're using rectified
nut'n linear nonlinear at each conv
layer then you probably or doesn't none
they're nonlinear it's not going to do
anything but there might be some case
where you want to yeah so it's basically
just it's something that this convair
function or class does it taxes on after
doing the convolution yes and yeah by
default it's rectified linear but you
can remove that or you can add any of
lasagna has a number of nonlinearities
built in or you can define your own
define my own I mean I experimented with
things like the parametrize relu I think
the leaky relative is sometimes gives
better results but yeah now I haven't
come up with any schemes in my own so
you can download the preach and weights
from this address and to load them and
then here we're gonna build this model
that's just gonna give us this
dictionary of layers and so again so was
Anya it tries to be simple so it doesn't
have something like a neural net class
or something like some other libraries
do basically you just define your layers
keep tracking them however you like I
like to put them in a dictionary with
informative names so to get those
pre-trained weights there's a helper
function set all Paramus so we're gonna
give it an output layer as usual it's
gonna go back through the network find
all the connected layers and we're gonna
give it
just a list of primary values so these
are a list of number arrays with
appropriate sizes so after this we have
a built model with the pre trained
weights in that and we have to do some
pre-processing to get images from disk
into a form that likes we have to you
know shuffle it into that batch channel
height width and also to some mean
subtraction cropping it to the right
size so this is just a helper function
to do all that try it out I'm gonna take
one of these images this is what it
looks like after going through the
cropping and everything it's waffles
let's see so just pre-processing at all
and then dividing into training and
validation sets I should clean this up
well sorry about all this
so now we're gonna take the network and
we're gonna discard the output
classifier which was trained for the
thousand classes of imagenet we're
create our own it's just a dense layer
connected to the second-to-last layer
with one unit for each of our classes
pancakes waffles and we're gonna have a
softmax non-linearity after that we do
the usual stuff define our symbolic
guerra output boss get our parameter
updates and define training functions
here is a fairly large network so we
have to use a smaller batch size and we
have been otherwise we'll run that of
GPU memory and then you know define
helper functions these we'll just pick a
random batch from our data feed it
through the training of the validation
function and then do our usual training
loop let's see so we can see after I
call the epochs but they're not really
um it's just a so after five sets of
twenty five batches
we've gone from 90% up to almost 94%
accuracy and we can then take a look at
how we do on the validation set looking
at some of these images so here the
value gray number is the true class and
it's either green if it's correct or
rather fine a mistake so you see we do
pretty well I mean some of these are
fairly I have some strange things and
I've changed it so yeah I mean 94% is
not amazing but before I went too much
farther I mean it's a nice quick
baseline and you'd probably go through
and you know clean this dataset a little
bit but you can also try you know
changing where you attach to your output
layer I'm adding some regularization
things like that
no there was a waffle iron class but
yeah I checked that there were these are
not in the original training day that I
do wonder if the waffle iron helps or
not this bill binding right yes sorry oh
yes yeah it's a lot more complicated
when you get a deep network to figure
out what the weights actually are
representing there's a lot of papers
that try different methods for
interpreting them and there's actually a
nice in the recipes repository someone
also has made this nice notebook that
tries out a couple of those basically
showing how you can try the visual as
what is being seen in different layers
in the network but you can see all these
different methods give very different
outputs and it's a little trickier I'll
tell what's actually happening so I
prefer just to go by the performance
metrics most of the time a question in
the back so I only have examples of
supervised but you know is definitely
used for a lot of unsupervised
oh yeah so one other point is so for
this sorry because we're trying to fine
tune it we assume our weights are
already pretty close to what we want so
I'm using a much smaller learning rate
than we did before so this is something
you'd also want to play with in a real
problem and you might also want to do
things like adjust the learning rate
have a higher learn if your output
classifier and again that's not
something lasagna does automatically but
something you could easily do by
separating this list of parameters into
the ones for your output layer and the
other layers and defining a different
learning rate for them running low on
time so this is another thing it's
something that came out I think this
summer neural art you may have heard of
these people found a really interesting
way to blend a style of a painting with
the content of a photograph so this is
just a example of how you can do that in
lasagna
basic idea is that you compute the
activations at some deep layer in your
network and then look at the correlation
between different filters and then
compare that optimize the difference
between that for your your style and
your content images well or started
between degenerate and your style images
and also the activation differences
between your content and your generated
image so this uses that same vgg Network
actually this is I think vgg 19 it's
just got a few more convolutional layers
in it it's defined in the same way we
have pre trained weights and same
pre-processing stuff so basically
there's some of the so this is the
content image photograph some buildings
and our style is starry night anything
and so we have to define a expression
for this thing called the gram matrix
which just gives us that correlation
between different feature channels oh
sorry so like how soon before like for
each convolutional kernel you apply it
to an image and you get out an image and
you call that like a feature or
activation image so basically you know
they're changing I mean it's just
terminology like you could consider the
output after one of these convolutional
layers to be like a feature map yeah
although in practice you would have like
a batch of but yeah you'd say like the
the feature map at some layer for a
particular example has some values
so yeah I guess and we have like a
Content loss which is just a squared
distance between so here we're giving it
to these would be feature maps or
collections of feature maps and we have
the style loss where we basically start
with the same thing we calculate this
grande matrix and then we calculate the
squared difference between those for the
two images and this was just another
thing that pen eliza's differences
between neighboring pixels which helps
make the output less noisy so to do this
we take the the loss at several
different layers in the network and
depending on which ones you pick you'll
get sort of different outputs so I'm
going to act fast and so here's an
example of the other I was talking about
before like we can define different
coefficients for these different
portions of the loss function and
finally we just you know sum up to these
different things to get a final
expression again we just as usually take
a gradient respect to that photo loss
I'm making defined functions for it
so some of that's kind of interesting
here too is for this particular method
stochastic gradient descent does not
work very well what works well is this
l-bfgs optimizer and as far as I know no
one's implemented that in the--and
rectly but what you can do is you know
you can hook in to scifi you can get
your outputs from piano pass them into
that and then pass the results back into
the-- I know and it's a little
roundabout but it it works fine that's
it yeah so that happens on the CPU so
maybe it doesn't work fine it's not it's
probably not as fast as doing it the GPU
but I think most of your time is
actually computing these these
convolutions so it doesn't really slow
you down too much to do the optimization
on the CPU so this is some examples of
what looks like we start from a noise
image you start to get some of the color
and texture appearing after some more
iterations you know you get more texture
then you start to see some of the
content coming in and you draw in the
final image
it doesn't really found the minor
unfortunately but I think this looks
really cool and if you go there lab and
look at what else they've done they've
generated some really amazingly
realistic texture images with a very
similar method where they're not trying
to optimize content but just texture and
it's it's kind of crazy how well it
works so this is just an example of you
know what you can do with this stuff I
mean this paper came out and I was able
to implement this and you know a couple
of days because of all the stuff that's
already you know available all the tools
are there
so another thing you can try a recurrent
neural networks so this is sort of
different it's kind of somewhat a
convolution but it's a different idea
that you're going to process a sequence
of data and basically you're going to
apply like the same weight matrices to
each time step you have some so each
time step you have some input value and
you have a hidden state that persists
from your last time step and you're
going to apply some matrices that tell
you how to compute a new hidden state
from the previous and the current input
and so one thing that you can do that
this is kind of interesting is take some
input text and try to train your model
to predict what the next character in
your text will be and if it can learn to
do that then you can sort of sample from
that and get an output sequence that
looks somewhat like your your training
data
it's got similar vocabulary and sort of
phrasing so you may have seen a char R
and then which was a example that was
pretty popular of this people have
applied to a lot of different things
like political speeches magic cards in
general all sorts of interesting
sequences this way so I decided to try
this out using data from patent claims
which was a freely available data set
and so this is what some of the the
training data looks like it's just
sentences describing claims and patents
so you could do this either at like a
word level you have like a 1 cotton
coating for each word and your
vocabulary but it's easier to do if you
do it just at the character level so
here I'm tackling a vocabulary that's
just the distinct characters that occur
in the corpus and then calculating
mappings from characters to integer and
one-hot representations and so I'm gonna
look at defined network that's gonna
look at sequences there are 50 steps
long and I'm gonna have a recurrent
layer with 200 hidden units in it so the
Train it created a new area that's gonna
sort of randomly pick sentences from
this corpus and feed them to me in
sequence of 50 characters but something
we want is that we want to make sure
that subsequent samples from this
generator give us the next 50 characters
in the sequence because we want to we
don't wanna have these you know jumps so
if you look here I'm just taking some
samples for my generator so you can see
that these sentences align with each
other and then to actually use this a
train we want to take in some text we
wanna give out a a convert that from
characters into integer indices and then
we also want to define targets which is
just the same sequence but delayed or
move forward by one character so the
shape of our day is a little bit
different weekend we have a batch
dimension we have a sequence length
dimension and then we have one
dimensional data input and again we
define our input variables except we
need to do something a little bit
different which is that we need input
variables for the
the hidden state because we want to
we're going to save the output in state
after at the end of each sequence and
then see that in at the start of the
next sequence and we have we have a two
layer Network so we need to do that
twice so here defined input layer find
that what's called GRU layer and so
we're gonna give it this primer hidden
in it we're just gonna tell it how to
map that symbolic variable into the
initial hidden state and then we got a
second layer same exact thing so to get
the output from this we want to go back
from the hidden state which is this 200
dimensional vector into a character and
to do that we're going to have a dense
layer where we have one unit per
character so we're gonna and we're going
to have a soft max I'm gonna Airy so
that's going to give us a mapping from
200 men tional vector to a probability
distribution over the characters but one
complication in that is we first have to
reshape this output which has you know
batch sequence feature dimensions
because we don't want our dense layer to
be connected to our the different time
points in the sequence we want each time
point to be processed independently so
we do a little trick where we just merge
the sequence dimension into the batch
dimension with this reshape layer and
then after the decoder we reshape it
back so that we get an output for each
time point so that's our output there
and in addition to getting the
probability distribution we're also
going to need the hidden States so here
we're using get output but we're doing a
little bit differently whereas before we
would give a single a layer here we give
a list of the layers so we're going to
take the hidden from the first layer
hidden to from the second layer and then
the probability distribution from output
and again we just give our input
sequence and the hidden state we're only
interested in the final time step so we
just index that you need to do a little
reshaping to do that across ninth Street
Lofts
and again we end up at the loss function
as usual so these networks are a little
more complicated to train they tend to
have stability problems because you're
if you're repeatedly applying the same
matrix over and over so some common
things to do or to take your gradients
clip them to a maximum value also apply
like a total norm constraint to them so
is there some helper functions that will
do this
these modifications for you then we're
using update function we're compiling
our training function which now we have
to give it in addition to our input our
targets we also have to give it the
initial values for the hidden state and
we're gonna compute several outputs let
me train this thing so this takes
something like an hour to train but you
can blow the pre-trained that is here
and then we can also calculate
prediction function where we don't give
it a target value input and so to make
it run faster for prediction something
we can do is we're not going to give it
fifty character sequences we're just
gonna step through it one time step at a
time
so we rebuild a network where we've just
changed sequence length to one and but
all the parameters are the same shape so
we can just stuff our pre-training
values back in there in order to get an
initial state to the network we're going
to sample a random sentence from the
validation corpus and we're gonna feed
that through there before checking our
output so do that you basically call the
prediction function with character from
the primer
these hidden states are initially zeros
and you get out a prediction and the new
hidden states and you repeat that so we
take yeah we repeat that for every
connection on the primer then we do the
same thing but now we're actually taking
that prediction we're sampling from that
distribution and then we're taking that
character as adding it to our generated
sentence and then feeding that sample
character back in is the next input and
so we're going to do this until we get
to a line break and so you can see the
text that comes out is fairly
intelligible these are mostly real words
and you could maybe see this as a patent
claim so one interesting you can think I
also do is this let's call it
temperature softmax so you can change
the normalization of that distribution
and even you can lower the temperature
and that will make a less it'll make it
stick closer to what it's seen so you
might get less things like Ventor but it
will also become more conservative so
you might see a start repeating whereas
it gets stuck in a loop where it says
you know the same thing again like to
the variation I have to the variation of
over and over again so you can play with
the temperature to see how the effects
of giant text I think
I think I'm not gonna go into this we're
almost out of time this is just a
another example you can do a similar
thing but you can initialize with a
feature vector derived from one of these
deep convolutional networks so you can
take a picture use that as your initial
hidden state and you can train it on
this data set of sentences describing
pictures that people put together and
you can get things that kind of make
sense I don't think this network is
trained particularly well but you know
this one says dog and cat in it so you
can kind of feel like maybe it's working
yeah I mean this looks like a stuffed
animal I'd buy that but people have also
taken this much further where you can
then you can detect different portions
of the image and put that in as separate
features and then you can get much more
interesting things where I sit and I say
you know a cat is sitting next to a dog
yeah incurs yet a little bit fun so
finally I just want to talk briefly
about extending lasagna which is
something that you're definitely
encouraged to do so it's supposed to be
very easy to define your own layers if
there's an operation that you want to do
that's not available basically all you
have to do is define a class from sub
classing the base layer class you have
to implement get output four which is
going to take something out of
expression apply your operation to it
and then return the expression and if
whatever you're doing changes the output
shape you just have to take a shape
tuple which is just a tuple of either
constants or nones calculate what the
new shape will be and return that
so those three operations are all you
have to do and then you can use the
whole rest of the framework so this is
just an example I did for something
called fractional pooling which is like
that - the pooling layer but it uh it
can do things like downsampled by like a
factor of 1.5 by sort of randomly taking
pixels with some probability depending
on that factor and this is kind of an
interesting thing because
it will give you different outputs each
time you run it I'm so like this is a
picture of Rubik's Cube unfortunately
you can't get these both my screen but
you can see they sort of get warped in
different ways because the down sampling
changes and this is another thing can
help regular eyes your network they
provide overfitting it can also let you
you know down sample slower so you
preserve more details as you go through
network are they more questions time um
that's a good question I did in believe
in here no I did not and this yeah so
it's it's basically just so there's
dropout layers are a very common thing
and you can also these regularization
functions like if I wanted to l2 I would
just say I could say regular is Network
params and that would give it the output
layer and that would give me a freshen
that corresponds to an l2 penalty on
each parameter in that layer or I could
pass it individual parameters and then I
the coefficient yeah so once you did
this you would get an expression you
would just add that to your loss
function and it was all happen
so there's some other alternative I mean
I do want theano or just alternatives in
general okay
so there's other piano alternatives like
Karis and Pilar and two are some big
ones they tent like each one tends to
have a different audience so Karis is
maybe better if you want like a
scikit-learn style interface where you
can you know give it ex-wife it predicts
there's also other things like cafe
which i think and torch personally I
like Python so I'm kind of sticking to
the base libraries
although cafe is also pretty nice been
around for a long time it works well and
I think it has a bit of a speed
advantage one thing about the you know
if you've been trying to run any of this
stuff you may have noticed it takes a
while when you compile functions that
usually only happens the first time
it'll cash a lot of stuff so but it's
definitely a drawback when you're trying
to rapidly experiment you might have to
wait you know for seconds or minutes to
compile your expressions but I think it
has the advantage that defining new
stuff from a mathematical formula is
pretty simple like you don't have to
write a lot of code so that I just has
the big advantage
you me in terms of input or what layer's
okay yeah I mean I think there's a lot
of trial and error I think this this vgg
structure is pretty common I've used it
for a lot of different problems not this
exact structure but the idea of a few
convolutions followed by a cooling
repeated until you get to a small output
and then either fully connected layers
or you can use one-by-one convolutions
over your output map that seems to work
quite well there's other things like the
Google net or the inception Network for
sometimes sometimes those give better
results but I think they're harder to
optimize I'm just more complicated not
really I mean it's it's from this paper
very deep convolutional networks they
defined a number of variants of it there
that they tested on image net but it's I
mean that's how I would characterize the
basic idea is just convolutions and
pulling yeah so the big thing you want
to do is monitor overfitting so you do
what people say you should do is make
the network large enough the or fits and
then add regularization and that usually
takes the form of dropout layers which
are kind of randomly remove some of the
feature activations in different places
yeah
okay well thank you all for coming